well it used to be easy to remember the
things in America that were racist they
were obvious things burning crosses
wearing white robes swastikas you get
the point now almost every day something
new is being declared racist by whoever
decides what's racist Betsy Ross has now
racist the National national anthem is
racist and now as of this week one of
America's first flags the Gadsden flag -
one that reads don't tread on me it's
been a pro Liberty symbol for almost 250
years but when actor Chris Pratt wore a
shirt with the flag Yahoo which is a
sort of news organization ran an article
suggesting the shirt choice reflected
quote white supremacy
Dean Cain is an actor in the star of the
recent film Gosnell we just spoke to him
about this here's what he said what is
going on here
always a pleasure always a pleasure
Tucker I am stunned
I don't know I mean it's shocking to me
I am wearing a shirt right now oh my
gosh it says coffee or die but it's a
join or die back in the old days the
Benjamin Franklin political cartoons
from back in the day there's nothing in
the world racist about the Gadsden flag
nothing at all I mean that that flag
symbolizes liberty and independence and
I think part of the reason they go after
Chris Pratt for that is because Chris
Pratt is a big supporter of our military
he's played Navy SEALs and things of
that nature he's he was there for the
Murph challenges that I've seen him do a
lot of things for our troops they like
him they respect him and a lot of our
troops like that flag as well it's so
it's nothing but independence and
freedom and I can't see a thing about it
that's racist or white supremacy or
anything of that nature maybe it's
because I think he's conservative and
they want to attack him so I'm sure well
that was that's true but I sense a
pattern here so our earliest flags are
national anthem
our statues our history itself what
they're really arguing is that America
as a country is illegitimate yeah
unfortunately that is what they are
arguing listen we did not have a perfect
beginning no country has right we are in
order to you know we're striving for a
more perfect union meaning that we were
never
perfect to begin with will never be
perfect will continually try and make it
better and better but just because of
those things happen in the past we are
we are forged from that history but you
know those things shouldn't be taken
down they shouldn't be poo pooed and
people can't co-op them if you don't let
them you know this flag it's a big part
of our our our heritage so many of my
friends love the Gadsden flag and they
that don't tread on me symbol of the
rattlesnake you know who is eternally
vigilant and and won't won't attack you
unless provoked
was a big symbol for the United States
and it still is and for good reason
that's exactly right
so but it's easy for you and me to say
that I mean I I give my opinions for a
living you're completely out of the
closet people know what your views are
you've taken your lumps already but for
people like Chris Pratt who were not
explicitly political this is dangerous
isn't it to be called names it very well
could be and fortunately for me I'm old
enough to feel like you know what it
doesn't matter to me out I'll voice my
opinion I don't you know I'm not racist
in any way shape or form
I'm not even completely white but I've
been called a white supremacist I've
been called a Nazi you know Godwin's law
I've been called all of those things you
know I it's it's craziness but but that
people are doing that and people like
Chris Pratt who listen the guy's a major
movie star I think he's a fantastic
actor is very funny but it could be
dangerous for a guy like that absolutely
and and and that's that's not okay it's
not okay at all team Cain a brave man
great to see you as always thank you for
coming on tonight
Tucker happy - thank you sir